starboard 6 portion of the International
Space Station
they're going to be starting on the
first major task of today's space walk
which is to Route these cables to
prepare for future installation of solar
arrays
all right so I've been where my safety
tester comes in
here
on my left this time bro
now what
for my last week so there's my last uh
giving a standard time yeah
if you can spot your uh waste Runner and
release the one you're hooking now
with another local and then yeah delete
that one
okay then this one okay that was clearer
[Music]
is also
catching that uh better
release it and just
I bring it on the red
it really just
okay not clear now yes you are thank you
side tables
and Sultan we see again at the work side
as well and just note for your guys
awareness we have Sultan's helmet cam we
don't have Steve's at the moment
um so Sultan if that is the red Barber
pulled cables then you have the right
ones
and your first step is to wire tie those
to the right mid strut handrail with a
pre-stage wire tie
all right I see the right cable and I
see
is one Bravo with the
Sharpie line
we have both cameras back and Sultan
that's those are good words that's the
right one
uh
and just a reminder as you're routing
these the wire ties will go to the
mid-stret handrails that are pre-stage
and then all of the slack will be back
toward the mass canister on the long
handrail
look at that coffee
in this view from Steve Bowen's helmet
camera in the background you can see
Sultan al-nayadi both astronauts now at
the S6 truss working two route cables
that will be used upon installation of
future irosas those are international
rollout International Space Station roll
out solar arrays
the modification kits that they're
working on were installed on a previous
spacewalk
all right
three turns on the mid
to the app
we copy the wires tie on the midstret
and heading toward the mass canister
okay and I have the same on the
headstrot and the three stage Wi-Fi it's
got three twists
copy three twists on the mid-strut
handrail and you two are attending slack
outboard to the mass canister long
handrail with long wire ties
all right four wire drives all the way
out
foreign
auts helmet cameras you can get a
glimpse at that mirror that they wear on
their wrist the
the panel on the international or on the
astronauts spacesuit it's on the front
of their spacesuit and all of the dials
uh
Wi-Fi or we use something from
and Sultan you could use the long wire
tie that's there integrated on the cable
well thanks
for the app try to make it look pretty
all right
and as you tack those down uh just one
final trick for you both to ensure that
the uh no Wing tabs were knocked and the
the cables are still connected to
themselves
same on the right side as well and I
have three wire uh three Clips on the
wires eye
the long hand rail
okay copy good work so the next step for
both of you is to go to your respective
upper strut so Steve on the left upper
strut and you're going to be right
toward the center pad so just up from
where you are and Sultan to the right
upper strut to the mli Gap near the
center pad
re pad
res
and good call Sultan keeping people
happy down here and just a reminder you
do have photos of this area on your cuff
Pages if you need a reference
all right
I think I'm in a good position all right
thanks
in the background of this view from
Steve Bowen's helmet camera you can see
the curvature of the earth as we prepare
for an orbital sunrise on the
International Space Station all right
Steve you're going to be closing the mli
Gap that's near the center pad you can
use integral mli wire ties or wire ties
from your brt as needed
and if needed ensure the flat side of
the mli wraps underneath the non-flop
side before securing with the integrals
and we want to just ensure that there's
no metal showing
they understand
and if you look just past your work site
you will see a beautiful sunrise about
to happen if you need to adjust visors
accordingly I do
I do see a beautiful sunrise
that Sunrise coming one hour and 43
minutes into today's spacewalk as the
station is flying over the North Pacific
Ocean
brackets that is okay
and Sultan say again you said you're at
the midstret
uh yeah the upper side is the office for
Steve now I don't wanna
go there I'm saying I want to start with
the rightness trust to the mountain
bracket
station
so we're not anticipated at the right
mid strut on this side uh needs to be
looked at but you can on the upper stret
on the other side near the mounting
bracket you can go toward where the n14
bolts are so it's just on the left side
of the upper Bolt
so if you
pull the square mli with the two bolt
holes over the M14 Bolt Bus
and I think I've seen this in my life
you all want to take a quick look
I see no metal showing
and Steve we're taking a look at that
right now we'll also taking your call
the right upper strut is kind of right
in front of you if you're in a good
position to get both of them uh you can
get that one too
right now both astronauts are modifying
some mli multi-layer installation
insulation
on the modification kit
this View and Steve Bowen's helmet
camera and to the right of your screen
you can see emirati astronaut Sultana
and Sultan we're uh we're talking about
the mli down here so on that mid strut
we expected that the mli to be out of
config at those two bolts that are right
in front of you it actually looks like
they're pretty good but right by your
right hand it looks like there's an mli
flap sticking up on that strut so we're
just wondering if you could maybe adjust
those wire ties and get that flap more
securely down on the whole midstret
it is uh
two balls and Instagram
on my right hand side that you need to
be secure
so now it's off to kind of your left but
uh wherever you see a flap sticking up
you can go ahead and Tack it down
all right let's see it
in and uh how does that look on the
other side
right there
a little bit
more
and Steve those look uh those look
pretty good
if you can just kind of back up a little
bit and give us a good heck of scan and
then we'll move on to the left mid
stretch
ER
iCal
that looks
[Music]
thank you
and for Steve we're good with the MLA on
the upper struts nice work so you can
move on to the left mid strut we expect
the there was an mli gap between the
collar bolts and the mounting bracket
but similar words to what I gave Sultan
if you see other mli that looks out of
config uh we will we would love it if
you could snug it up a little bit but
we're expecting the left mid strut
between the collar bolts and the
mounting bracket
this structure the collar bolts
all right I will take a look
and Sultan that's uh I see you kind of
work in the collar bolts on that strut
uh that is that's definitely a little
bit out of config especially on a mass
canister side
uh so we'll definitely take a good cinch
up on that one
and for both of you if it's possible
after we fix the mli to not translate on
it that would be a preferable thing
I'm trying to work on that
ah
on this uh
extra shorts I see some it will Expose
and I'm not sure about the
the mid strut middle area what the one
you pointed just now
to me from this side is covered
you have a view on it see from this side
there's a gap on this side okay you may
have to come inside to look at that
how does my look by the way since you
were looking for us at me
um you discovered I didn't see any
um
that point two wire size
the middle is explored exposed from here
oh no
you say it
okay I see it hold on
this is Mission Control Houston one hour
52 minutes into today's space walk
the fourth spacewalk of the Year eighth
for Steve Bowen and the first for sultan
al-nayadi
we are in a satellite Handover with the
International Space Station expect to
regain communication shortly
the astronauts are now working on
routing
they've completed their cable routing
portion of this specific mod kit work
they are now working on the mli or the
multi-layer insulation
ensuring it's properly placed to protect
the hardware itself
good
evening
after the astronauts complete the work
on the 1B mli they will move over to the
1A mod kit
and continue the same type of
multi-layer insulation work
there won't be any cable routing
necessary at that mod kit but at the
completion of this work the astronauts
will have prepared these areas
for future solar array installation
later this summer
but still between these wire ties
in there to hold the stem
I can give you I get one I'll get it
North take a look at yours I use
reference is covered now
until 10 we're back with you after the
Handover in Sultan we were we appreciate
the good thorough inspection on the
right mid strut so as Steve as you
continue to work that left mid stretch
Sultan you can move to the mounting
bracket to cycle the soft capture
features
first
I have one on my side right
there is one on your side there's kind
of one in the center one on the left and
one on the right
so the expected config when you get
there is that they're going to be pulled
down and in the Little J hook uh we just
want you to pull it out release the soft
capture and then re-engage the soft
capture
just for your awareness we are back with
you on voice we don't have video quite
yet
okay
in the center of your view here is NASA
astronaut and McLean serving as the
ground IV she's the one you hear
speaking directly with the astronauts on
the International Space Station on the
spacewalk
they communicate with McLean alone to
ensure
streamlined communication and not too
many voices coming from the room
to her left is Costa madrivas he is
communicating with the astronauts inside
the International Space Station who are
continuing to go through their work day
okay we're at 6 40. yeah get a long
large eye on there with three clips
for both of you just a status uh you're
at two hours or just about at two hours
pet and you're still slightly ahead of
timeline
all right how does that look now look
pretty good
right arm okay all right now let's drop
my throat or the big struts it was on
events towards the right hand
in the new YSI and uh
opponent between the met and the after
speeding here yeah right there
this is fine if you can start the not
yeah I think if I get married
and Steve good catch we were just
looking at the same thing
and Sultan
from your angles that close up that Gap
absolutely yes okay so I should put on
another Wi-Fi there all right that will
take a second
and Sultan correction to my last uh
answer you asked about the soft capture
features there's one on your side and
then two are kind of tended moreover
toward Steve's side on the bottom of the
mounting bracket
you want me to do all three
we do need to do all three
astronauts continue working on the
multi-layer insulation
okay
this multi-layer insulation protects the
modification kits where future solar
arrays will be installed
and that view that we had from Steve
Bowen's helmet camera International
Space Station flying over Illinois
recycle
copy thank you
and Sultan so the last thing we'll take
from you is a hecka scan of all mli
anything you could see on the right side
and on Steve's side we just want to make
sure there's no gaps in the mid and
upper struts and that the mounting
bracket is clear of mli
okay I'm scanning the upper strut now
than the other side that I can't see
covered
and Steve as you finish up the same
thing yeah
same thing for me Steve just a good heck
of scan of any of the mli pieces that
you can see in a verification that
there's no mli on the mounting grounds
all right let's see what we got here
how's that for Stan so far go upwards to
the mid
put this one off
we appreciate the views we are talking
about it
all right gentlemen good good news you
did so good on this one that we're gonna
head to 1A and do the same thing
all right
coffee
and before translating uh please at
glove inspection hap check and a
gauntlet check from both
all right let me get back down on
extra zero then
um
inspection sorry on my left hand let's
see
index finger
fingers
pause my right hand okay
fine I have
done still
okay Sultan we copy your left index
finger and you can confirm that that's
only the RTV
all right my gloves
the astronauts are conducting a glove
and hap check
they take a look at their gloves often
to report the status
we copy Steve a reminder on your way to
180.
good check have dry and reminder Steve
to pick up the wire tie caddy on your
way
thank you
again we just saw those glove checks the
astronauts
it's clear it's clear
thanks
you can come back this way and follow me
um
everybody
before we can move on
astronauts are periodically asked to
take a look at their gloves to ensure
there is no major damage additionally
they are asked for a hap check that's a
helmet absorption pad they're able to
lean their head back
and feel that helmet absorption pad to
ensure there's no liquid in the helmet
this is Mission Control Houston it's two
hours and six minutes into today's
spacewalk
the astronauts have just completed the
work at the 1B mod kit after routing
some cables and
uh modifying the multi-layer insulation
they'll now head over to the 1A mod kit
where they will do the same installation
work as previously
all right I have the Wi-Fi Academy ready
for me
copy your next stop for both of you will
be to pick up your uh green hook
from years from 2003 Sultan's from 2004.
the green hooks are next
we cut this down behind my mini work
station
these beautiful views coming from NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen's helmet camera
today is Bowen's eighth spacewalk
looking down below the International
Space Station just flew over Puerto Rico
you can also see the solar arrays
stretching out from the International
Space Station
come up to your green hooks after you
pick them up
you're going to be moving Nader kind of
down towards your feet the way you're
oriented right now next to the A-frame
to get over to the 1A side
okay
friend yeah okay
yes we recommend outboard of the A-frame
foreign
hook
and foreign
this is going to be a little bit of an
orientation change but as you're going
to go down towards your feet outboard of
the A-frame
and then you're going to continue
inboard
and you're going to end up with ev1
Steve you'll be on the right side of the
mod kit and Sultan on the left
down
okay so I am on the right side
and Steve we see you arriving there
your first uh Target is going to be the
right mid strut that's the first one
that we think may be problematic and
you're going to open the mli fasten
around the midstret collar bolt and
reset it
okay
the astronauts have now arrived at their
next work site
they will begin securing the multi-layer
insulation around the 1A mod kit
Sultan your first Target is going to be
the center pad of the left upper strut
so kind of the area that's that Steve
worked out at uh at the other area
and Steve on that right mid strut
there's a both the collar bolts we think
are problematic and then the area
between the collar bolts and the
mounting brackets
oh
look
foreign
aut Steve Bowen on the left easy to
identify thanks to the red stripes on
his spacesuit
on the right is UAE astronauts will turn
alnayadi he's wearing an unmarked suit
but if you look closely you can also see
the emirati flag on his left shoulder
and Sultan as you get up there you can
our suggestions you can either
reposition those integrals as you're
working if you need to use wire ties
from your brt and ensure that that flap
side is under the flatter side
the multi-layer insulation that these
astronauts are securing today helps
protect the structures that are on the
International Space Station they are
exposed to extreme varying heat and cold
while outside in the vacuum of space
this multi-layer insulation helps
protect against any extra stresses that
those temperatures can cause
ah
Sultan we're taking a look at the mli
the mli that's on the back of your right
hand right now that flap we think that
that needs to be laid down
first so it needs to be underneath
the mid struts
yeah that's correct that flap that's
kind of underneath the uh
yeah that one needs to go down first
that's right
understood
and you may be able to kind of pull
those integral ties around uh
around the strut and then before laying
down the second one
thanks
awesome
and Sultan we know that that one's a
little bit challenging and that there
may be some metal exposure you may need
to use a wire tie if you do just a
reminder not to put the wire tie over
the actual collar bolt but uh or over
the actual bolt but put it on one side
or the other
ah
a
remember
some information
outside power LED is on but the white
LED on the back of the laptop is not on
thank you
okay how does that look
and Steve that is buttoned up nicely uh
you have uh you got to go from the
mirror on that one so on your side uh
we can have you move to the right side
of the mounting bracket to cycle the
soft key capture features
okay
yeah
yeah Stephen I think you saw it as you
went by on that mid Strut by the
mounting bracket side it looks like the
inside of that
yeah
look at that let me cycle this one and
then I'll take care of that thank you
all right that Cycles is back in the day
almost that there it is
foreign
and I don't know if you see a view my
camera but uh
it's a long drive on the
section of the midstret
and Sultan that looks good to us right
now I appreciate that
and so Sultan if you just take a look
along that whole left mid strut between
the collar bolts and the mounting
bracket and just ensure that there's no
metal showing
New York
good work on that Steve we're looking at
the images
um well we have you right there just to
your right side there's a soft capture
feature so we saw you grab the middle
one I think you're going for it that
we'll need to grab that soft cap capture
feature on the right side and make sure
it's in the J hook
that one from the j-hook
and so that's the middle one yeah
there's one kind of over excellent
yeah I think I need to go back and be
able to assemble on a little bit more
okay copy
in the J here
I've pulled it down kind of cycle it in
let's get it back on
I think I have to go back and take a
little look at this thing okay copy
thanks and Sultan when uh as you move
off of there though oh you got all three
of them okay thank you
oh
so for sultan um we didn't take a heck
of scan of any of the mli instructors
that you see on any of the struts and
ensuring that the whole mounting bracket
is clear of mli
but I didn't look
and the
push rods are covered now
from metal exposed
okay can you see this shirt over here
on your side
over here your side now it's covered it
is covered now
and then on the upper struts
I see good and alive I don't see any
exposed Metals except for the screws
whatever if I can
that Sizer but I don't see any metallic
source
okay we copy
um so as we get the as we wait that's
not good as we await the final
yeah we copy we're waiting
yeah looking at the cables that they've
got
here
all right I need to go back from the UFO
expression
this view from NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen's helmet camera as he continues to
cover the mod kit structure with
multi-layer insulation
best size
it's a good view
good view
and Sultan that flap that's right in
front of you that you're kind of the one
you're playing with uh we may ask it to
uh well we will ask you to put a wire
tie around that please
now two hours and 30 minutes since the
spacewalkers switched their suits to
internal battery power kicking off the
start of today's spacewalk
yeah we are looking uh we're looking at
the views now
your pause right there the next thing
we'll need is a wire tie down on the
caddy
hold on
you're gonna fold this one piece of
the barrel here now
okay
I have
three one two three
one two three four five six seven long
ah
and I use the long and a short for my uh
beer key
and Steve sorry can you repeat the
quantities again
it's a seven long
short with it
one two three four five six yeah seven
long three shorts
seven long too short we are there with
you probably appreciate that count
like I said are you two
how long was short from my Yorkie
okay we copy
okay we've talked about the high
priority areas and we are happy with the
uh all of the mli fixes and the high
priority areas
uh we have one area that we'd like you
to take a look at if you think you can
get there without translating on the
nicely tacked up mli and that's on the
upper strut near the mass canister the
areas that you worked out at the 1B
Steve
on the left side we think that the mli
might be open just a little bit
side upper strut
let me get back up there
up here actually looks pretty good
look around
copy
yeah to get a good look on both those
I think the upper field looks pretty
good
and Steve are you able to get an eye on
both the left and the right uppers
yes
and I'll tell you the kind of
problematic area that we uh that we're
looking at is the left upper strut but
kind of on the back side from where
you're looking at all that on the mass
canister side and just if you can try to
get eyes on it it's kind of the area
that you worked out at the uh 1B
here
okay look at both sides of this left
upper strip
that looks good
right upper strut up at the top
the only good thing to look up at the
very top here
okay we keep talking about now
happy thanks Steve sure
two hours 35 minutes into the spacewalk
and we are in a Handover of satellites
that allow us to communicate with the
International Space Station
the astronauts continue to work on
securing mli multi-layer installation
on the modification kit
this comes after completing some cable
routing as well as additional mli
insulation
we're about five minutes to a Sunset and
sometime we just wanted to send you a
quick note we were looking at your
helmet lights and we think your left
side helmet light may not have been on
in the last Eclipse if you want to use
it
coffee
the modification kits where the
astronauts are working today will are
where we will have future irosas
International Space Station roll out
solar arrays installed if you see a view
of my camera
we see it now that looks beautiful thank
you
four new irosas have been installed on
the International Space Station
copy good work thank you Steve uh and
for both of you we can kind of back off
of the mud kit and take a look
all right quickly before the rain goes
down
that's the upper stretch
and that's right Frank
and as you guys uh
get reset off of that worksite uh Sultan
just a couple systems notes for you uh
we're about 10 minutes from where the OT
sensor readings had been seen to be
erratic before so just for your
awareness
and also just for your awareness we
think that your helmet lights um came
detached from your helmet and they're
being held on by the strap there's no
action needed for you but I'm just
letting you know that it might be a
little bit wobbly
and Steven Sultan we just got word from
the myrrh they are happy with your mli
work on one alpha so that will complete
this task
s okay
thanks
so to uh to get done with this work sign
uh Steve will have you hand the wire tie
caddy uh to Sultan and Sultan you'll
just carry it on your mws
uh and it that bayonet fitting might
keep it a little bit tighter onto your
mws and for both of you a glove half and
gauntlets before translation please
wait wait
I just open the front and slide you this
before I drop it back
if I can get it
I am amongst your feathers here
so let's not get too crossed
I'll see you leading off to the left
you're heading back to the right
um
do you want me to go ahead of you and
then pose
yeah I'm trying to figure out how best
to do that um I can do it I'll just uh
pick up my local and then I'll head oh
let me double track where mine is okay
let me get low so you're fighting
all right
all right let's hang up on something
hold on
there you go
ahead bro
all right
foreign
positions as you get to where your green
hooks were so Sultan our recommendation
is that you lead back out to 2004. and
then Steve follow him out to those that
where your green hooks were
and then Steve will lead the translation
back in big picture Steve your next task
is arm setup and Sultan yours is esp2
setup
that's 2004.
let's be able to get up there and swap
myself around
and before translation can we get a
glove and a hat from both of you
both gloves look good
that was dry
copy thanks Steve and for ev2 North
Canyon the glad
to North
and Harvest Drive okay copy thank you
so Steve you'll lead the translation in
you're heading to the Port City cart
and you will leave your anchors right
where they are pass the anchors and uh
Sultan you're going to be heading into
the esp2 work sites you're going to
follow Steve
until you get to the uh Cedar spur and
then you're gonna go down the cedar spur
all right so for the student until these
this bird then we'll head down to the
asb2
good words
and we're going to have you fairly near
the port airlock toolbox when you get
down there and this would also be a good
time to turn on the GoPro
foreign
coming up on two hours and 45 minutes
into today's space walk
this view from NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen's helmet camera
both spacewalkers have accomplished the
first major task of today which is
routing cables and modifying securing
mli multi-layer insulation to the mod
kits where future irosa arrays will be
installed
the astronauts are now translating to
their next work site you're sitting at
about two hours and 45 minutes pet and
you're about 10 minutes ahead of the
timeline and we just got the call that
all the inhibitored place for rfg so we
are going to pursue that task
the next task is for the astronauts to
retrieve the rfg
[Music]
's going on the cables hello
all right I think it's clear
I don't know what that's going on
next 100 yeah be enough
okay especially this doesn't feel behind
you again
another spot here
again the next task for our space
Walkers is to retrieve the radio
frequency group
part of the s-band antenna
the s-band antenna is our critical
command and data link to and from the
space station of course we do have
redundancy
but the rfg is the brains essentially
if you're out of something back there
the radio frequency group houses the
electronics High Gain and low gain
antennas on the s-band system
still grab back
you follow that back up
a little bit
the astronauts will remove the rfg and
bring it inside the space station
the wires folded so it's not back on
something
a little bit
let's see what's hooked on
okay let me stand this
The Intern
Varsity yep
okay it's been in 10 and it's coming
your way that's it
thank you
thank you very much
all right so you're
teller turns behind me
I need to get it up and over my head
I stand by until I come close to you
as he goes behind me
so where we want it for the next setup
for these tethers just for awareness is
Sultan should go from the anchor down to
a fairly by the port airlock toolbox
and Steve's yours will go from the
anchor to a fairly that you're going to
put on the lab stretch
yep
I need to solve
it because you're kind of goes behind me
but it's underneath my
my safety tether
so if you can get let me get uh
so let's give it up I want to go down
get over my head and I'll come up and
we'll clearly lost it
okay
are they close now or just right across
down so
can we get to each other
up from behind me and about put it back
above me
it's gonna go a little bit later as well
what
yeah
towards me just a little bit towards me
oh
be clear now okay sit in front of you
let me get back up here and take a look
excuse
me right now I
trust you
and that'll be fine
I agree okay
before
Electronics
as our astronauts continue to translate
to the next work site the International
Space Station is flying 261 statute
miles over the Indian Ocean West of
Australia
thank you
as you can see in The View
the astronauts do have lights on their
helmet to help them work during these uh
nighttime passes
all right Steve you're gonna go under
the Mt to the port Cedar cart and you're
going to be looking for the apfr in the
top left whiff which is with three and
it should have an integrass 8 on it
all right
I don't expect we're going to get to any
get ahead and I'm going to go around the
Superstar now
[Applause]
and copy Sultan yep you're going to head
down the seat of spur
and then you can turn on the GoPro and
you're going to fair lead on the port
west near the port airlock toolbox and
when you pause I have a couple words for
you on your glove
look at that
hey we're three is the one that's
currently in the middle under swing arm
trip
yes with three which is
that's correct papa papa and then we ask
you don't change the pitch setting for
translation and you can Stow that on
your brt
and the final setting for that one are
12 papa papa fox six uh for the arm and
you can set that anytime between here
and there
perfect
this view from Steve Bowen's helmet
camera as he picks up a an apfr
articulating portable foot restraint
as overheard he'll stood that on his brt
the body restraint tether
he'll then attach it to the Canon rm2
which will be used during the next task
when they remove the rfg the radio
frequency group and prepare to bring it
inside the space station
wow
I'm gonna go up to clear these uh
foreign
let us know if you need any assistance
yeah before making this watch I just
want to
figure out a wraps
we get across behind my place but
you want to go down and uh
to help you out here describe the apfr
no problem Steve
and yeah Steve would like you to head
back a little bit outboard to the other
side and see if you can help clear that
the only uh
done a lot of strutting My Fair leader
mental real healthier
that's okay
yeah we can cover with that plan
the uh garbage straddle supposed to go
down
that's the answer
on the starboard Lobster at handrail
it works
on the second second where are you right
now
okay I'll be up in a second I just
wanted to see him where you said that is
relative is it behind my place or
I just read for you I think it's on my
face
we
are
still I think you're clear
okay
I was right behind my PGT somehow
all right so you got it clear
you see it yeah okay they're heading
down
okay and we told them that are we
monitored Sultan you said that it was
cleared
it is clear and it was uh wrapped around
my PGT unfortunately
all right nicely done so you can
continue down the port airlock or down
the seat of spur to the GoPro and you
can turn that on and Steve you can go
down to the front side of esp2 as via
the lab and then the Gap spanner
on my way
they get this incorrectly
thing or limiting is meta to be two at
seven hours
all right got a fairly replace it
copy Fair leading place
okay cameras on
copy the cameras on so if you can go
over near the uh we're thinking on the
port with near the port airlock toolbox
and fairlead and then you're going to
translate around the side of esp2 where
you had where you stowed the acrylic bag
one and you're going to Stow the wire
tie caddy
hey it's coffee
foreign
a good position on the front of esp2
there your next step is going to be to
give Frank a go to GCA to the apfr
install and Ingress position so you just
want to position yourself to where you
are clear but can see everything
okay let me get myself there
now over three hours into the spacewalk
today
astronauts are preparing for the next
major task on their list
this is to remove the rfg the radio
frequency group from the s-band antenna
again the radio frequency group is the
computer and electronics that control
the s-band system
and this portion of the system will be
brought inside the International Space
Station before being returned to Earth
for refurbishment and eventual return to
the space station
foreign
you can Stow the wire tie caddy and then
I have a couple systems words for you
when you have time to look at your left
hand again
oh
all right come on
[Music]
yes
and then that's why Caddy will go into
integral events
and now sometime we're going to Stow the
wire tie caddy into crew lock bag one
at the same time
yes you can put it on any available
integral red
okay Frank you got to go to GTA to the
Ingress
the install in English position
GCA to published our published position
is 1.1 meters station ask and we're
starting motions
okay
good motion
foreign
ER to go
continue to published
topics
that's your published position
all right let me take a look
good
another 30 centimeters stationed out
the additional three zero centimeters
stationed out
multiple voices in the mix now as NASA
astronaut Woody hoberg inside the space
station is commanding the Canada arm 2.
Steve Bowen will
uh be on the Canon arm too
to help with the with some stabilization
for the rfg removal position
s
see the brakes are on you go for apfr
install and Ingress
foreign
and Steve you can install the apfr onto
the arm you're looking for 12 papa papa
Fox 6.
first whole time while you have that
okay yep good read back
first Sultan while you have that bag in
your hand you're going to retrieve the
large small red that's on the handrail
of that bag and you're going to put the
small hook onto handrail 8007
which is the same handrail that your
temps throwed on eight zero zero seven
copy small hook on
coffee
great view here of Steve Bowen as he
handles the apfr the articulating
portable foot restraint and places it on
the Canada arm too the latching and
Defector
okay
and of course we have another brief
satellite Handover
teams here in Mission Control Houston
continuing to monitor uh everything
about today's spacewalk including the
status of the astronauts inside the
space station of course our astronauts
outside and keeping up with those tasks
as well as the uh consumables for the
astronauts including their oxygen rates
inside the suits
copy black on black and we're just back
with you from a Handover so hold on call
the pull twist test we missed it hold on
photography uh
black on black it didn't twist it
feels like a fan but it hasn't twisted
baller is not going backwards
copy a couple notes for sultan while
Steve works at uh one is that we're out
of the range if you're erratic sensor so
we're not worried about that anymore for
your glove what we want you to do is
take a look at the flap and see if you
can look underneath it and make sure
that there's no additional damage to any
other of the glove structure other than
that RTV
and just a reminder that on the app
index finger you've got that Turtle skin
underneath that RTV as well
and I did report initially that that
slab has another RCB lab
but nothing is exposed
okay good words thanks for double
checking that uh so Sultan your next
um your next step is going to be to
pre-stage the long wire tie on the clam
shell mli so just double check that you
have a long wire tie left on your brt
okay if I'm gonna go to any from a
Ducati
I only have short on the market
okay yeah we we agree with that Sultan
sorry about that I should have kept that
before you put that in there so we'll
have you grab one long wire tie in the
clamshell M line
it's coffee and work
yeah I had a hard time with this
or black on black
in the caller
get a
it's like it's in there
color does not want to move
we're taking a look
at this little bit there we go now it's
black and black that cycle done
oh it came out
hello
okay now I got a 12.
10 o'clock on black but it's not it
okay we we copy that uh it might just be
on this soft capture
I'm sure
hold on
myself
all right now I got a good twist the
black on black
yeah collar is very stiff I think that's
a big part of this
it is in place
but uh okay
and we're checking to see we may have
you double check it
teams on the ground helping NASA
astronauts Depot and troubleshoot uh the
install of the articulating portable
foot restraint on the Canon arm too
meanwhile we saw the International Space
Station enter an orbital daylight
okay Steve we're going to have you give
that one more really good pull test and
rather than pulling on the boot plate if
you could live uh go down to where the
load limiter is just obviously making
sure you don't squeeze the paddles and
make sure we have a good pull test
and look
foreign
we appreciate the setup so your next
step is going to be to assist sultan
with the rfg setup
okay sorry
get off the
if you're far
so we can have one of you install the
long wire tie onto the clamshell moi
and we'll be assessing the clamshell mli
for snugness and then we also need to
retrieve the Eva scissors and cut the
mli strap
okay I have the wire Steve and I'll show
them now
slam show okay let me get cleaned up a
little bit
what's ybrt is Tangled upon
foreign
and Steve we think what you could start
doing is undoing the quarter turn
Fasteners on the mli tent
oh
I can do that
and Sultan you can move over to that
clamshell mli for the long wire tie
I'm just uh
53 degrees
in the end
surprisingly
can I drop my Greenhouse somewhere
there's a tension that the green Hulk is
we realized we pick the limits
but that's fairly Maybe
I'll check
and Sultan yes you can drop your green
hook
um so we recommend one one method would
be to fair lead over by the port airlock
toolboxes but you can also put your
green hook down to get your tumblers out
of the way wherever you see fit probably
toward the airlock on esp2
disregard that then I think it was uh
that's the red wheel caught behind the
ESP structure
I have been up to work yeah
foreign
Fasteners on the back side correct
uh nothing on the back just the uh
[Music]
yeah that's right it's just ISS forward
and uh on the High Gain side
there should there should be ten total
and then on the ISS starboard side
there's going to be a MLive velcro flap
that you can remove
okay
all right
foreign
and just a reminder on the a couple
questions for you guys around the
antenna we don't want to exert any more
than about seven pounds into the High
Gain antenna
we want to minimize loads on the low
gain antenna and once we open it up we
want to avoid avoid the white paint on
the rfg and minimize loading into the
flat face of the clam shell
I think that's enough
again interested on himself
as our space Walkers Begin work on
removing the radio frequency group as
part of the s-band antenna if you look
in the background at beautiful Earth
just above it is our moon
and Sultan once you get on there or once
you get that on there you can kind of
put your hands on the clamshell and
assess how much it moves on the antenna
itself this will be where Steve is
holding the rfg when we feed it into the
airlock
this
is
three times
so bring it back up no you don't have to
do that as well snap Maybe
okay that's fine
it'll help
you think I think he needs to talk it
back through at least one more time sure
and Steve by your left hand there's kind
of a velcro seam along the rfg you can
open that up getting ready to peel it
back whenever you're ready
all right all right make it good for the
last two quarter turns there
on this side
okay we'll do that
yeah quite reasonable
and Sultan your next step you can
retrieve the Eva scissors from the crew
lock bag one and we'll be cutting the
mli strap
all right
and Steve we'll have you stand by on the
mli until uh until we get the strap cut
okay
as we get that mli open reminder to both
of you that we've seen some mmod strikes
on the rfg and so we want to minimize
touching any potential MLB strike areas
and that Z93 paint area
okay let me uh
let me know my uh apfr settings I'll
make sure I'm good there was
apfr settings 12 papa papa Fox 6.
and I think I'm there
okay I have my scissors epsilvers
hands
um
this is my location for the cut
copy Sultan and uh when you're at the
clam shell can you give us any words on
how snug the clamshell is on the rfg
antenna
and
[Music]
I don't think it's a like a proper
grabbing point but it's definitely close
with the wire tie best effort and it's
tight
but it is uh
rotating if I if I do
that it does reset
okay with that then Sultan we are go for
you to cut the mli strap nearest the
clamshell that connects the clamshell to
the tent
the first step in removing the radio
frequency group is to remove the mli the
multi-layer insulation that has
protected the hardware
the rfg was not designed to be retrieved
during an Eva
that you did get the small end of the
large small on the handrail correct
it is about the large Focus feel free
where do I need to put it
okay copy yeah the small hook on the
handrail and then uh we have a request
for you to close these em uses or the
scissors until you're ready to use them
Alfie I'm ready to use them
okay you're gonna cut that mli and we're
about 15 seconds from a Handover
coffee
we are back with you on voice waiting on
video
the mli is cut
for uh
rewards on that
it is God and without God nor is it
you're on the
side there's a small celeb on the
um
show all right copy you can store the
EBS scissors and the crew lock bag and I
hope that was fun we rarely get to cut
things on Eva
and your next step is going to be
removing the mli tent and attaching it
to that large red that you have staged
all right
Steve we're going to have you move
toward the arm and have you start
performing your safety tether stop and
getting ready for Ingress
okay let's talk you through that real
quick
sure I'm doing it right yes so for the
safety tether swap you want to make sure
your waist tether is down
and your first step is to lock your
ingredients
copy green is luck check that your green
hook gate is closed and the hook is
locked
screen update is closed and locked
you can now relocate your yellow hook to
the ssrms handrail tether point
okay going on to the yellow Ultra zone
for the ssrms
we'll put it on these forward
teleport
that's Jake low slider locked
copy gate closed hook locked on the
yellow on the handrail tether Point your
next step is to attach your green hook
to esp2 handrail 8011
foreign
one
copy Greenhouse installed
copy the green hook on 8011 and you can
unlock the green tether reel
unlock green feather reel
and when you do that you want to verify
that the tether reel and the cable are
clear of the rfg removal path
yeah I will be probably one if I get the
uh
wait for an outside clear of it
all right
foreign
[Music]
hook
for my
breastfeeding Defender
and put it on the other side of the
greenhouse I can just send you the
greenhouse never mind
if I do the Greyhound again for the
other side of my Red Hook yeah that's
where we're just getting to if we leave
your load pass and then we can just redo
the green hook
yep I agree with you
foreign
and with that Steve we uh that completes
the safety tether swap procedure
so you can just verify your load path is
and is clear your next step is going to
be to Ingress the apfr
Sultan we see you opening and
restraining the tent mli
and let us know when you have that on
the large hook of the large small red
it is attached already to develop a loop
operation
copy good words and uh would also take a
baseline inspection when you have a
chance of the white paint on the rfg
from what uh
all right let's feel much better about
that
as Steve Bowen prepares to Ingress the
articulating portable foot restraint
Sultan aniadi is removing some
multi-layer insulation from the s-band
antenna
this will allow them to more easily
access and remove the rfg the radio
frequency Group which will be taken
inside the space station for Steve as
you get to the Ingress you're going to
make sure your tools and tethers are
clear that the Ingress Aid is stowed you
can attach your waste tether to the
Ingress Aid
I will detach myself from
esp2
and Ingress with apfr
and Sultan when you're uh
inspection will take any words on any
damage or flaking that you may see and
then we'll go for the cables
foreign
[Music]
connection I do see just smaller ones
all around I don't know if you see my my
camera
Maybe
we see a little bit in your camera if
you look up a little bit more we've got
a good view of the rest of the box from
Steve's camera
yeah that's a good inspection we
appreciate that Sultan um so you're now
go to dmate the Sasa cables from the rfg
and give us an inspection that's gonna
be the P9 from the j9 and the P1 from
the J1
and then you're going to get the Caps
from the crew lock bag and cap both ends
j9
from P9 and then uh J1 from P1 thanks
that's correct and I have English the
apfr
anytime
thank you for all my creditors are clear
of
ESP
and I think I'm ready to go to the
uh
removal position yep and from Steve
we'll get a 11 and a half check from you
but before we take the count for robo uh
Sultan are you good for your next couple
steps you're going to demate those
cables you're going to retrieve the cap
keeper from the crew lock bag and then
you're going to put the caps and the
plugs on both cable ends and uh both box
connections
ever
that's pretty forward actually only
backwards double centered and I think
the other one
be a quick inspection then you confirm
the efficiency
and Steve if you want to give a double
check on your feet on the apfr we
thought we might have seen a little bit
of movement on your uh left heel
correction right here right now I was
checking it yeah when I try to play with
it
all right
V1 good pins
and Alpha good Emi events ready to cover
all of these
okay Sultan we're you are going to uh
get all the caps and we'll get words on
those after the uh after the art we move
the arm and so for Steve did you get
your glove and half check
all right Steve you can uh you have the
comms to give Frank the go to GK to the
rfg retrieval position
we're trying to get my right foot back
in first
that field trip
okay Frank
I need to go station forward 30
centimeters I gave you and then you can
well GTA TV
apparently
[Applause]
removal position
we copy brakes are coming off to begin
GPA to published we'll start with about
30 centimeters stationed forward
followed up with 70 centimeters
stationed starboard starting motion
station forward that's downstairs thank
you
one thing
that's the voice of NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg who will be controlling the
canadarm 2 as he begins to relocate
Steve Bowen on the end of the Canon arm
tube it'll put him in a proper position
to remove some bolts that are on the rfg
Sultan in the background has dmated two
cables from the radio frequency group
and is installing caps to protect them
for future use
okay we need the team to review late
note 9 City street Bravo
my name is Passion this is needed for
the rfg cleanup so TV
days
so you can see we're starting motion
station forward for 24 centimeters
I'm ready
good motion
okay Steve starting motion station
starboard for seven zero centimeters
looks like good motion
stop motion motion
okay let me take a look
foreign
[Music]
centimeters
station
we were going starboard right so
stationary
later
okay see if we copy 20 more centimeters
continue station starboard and then 20
centimeters stationed neighbor Nader I
think that'll do it
all right starting motion station
starboard
promotion
copy good motion
genius I'm sorry I had that backwards
since I'm upside down
especially if we copy uh station Zenith
that should be towards your feet and
your left side thank you
starting motion stations in
great motion
you can stop motion there
yeah that's a great position thank you
GCA can please stand by for bricks
see if brakes are on your go for RFP
boat release
all right thank you
and we copied that the brakes are back
on so Steve a big picture when Sultan is
done installing that caps he's going to
hand you a large small red
and you're going to put that large small
rat onto the rfg and then you're going
to be driving the bolts
some acronym breakdown for you
um Steve Bowen will be receiving
he will be attaching a retractable
equipment tether to the radio frequency
group since that will soon be released
from the space station
he'll be using a PGT or pistol grip tool
to release eight structural bolts
after those have been released he will
release one jacking Bolt
Sultan al-nayadi is meanwhile finishing
up removing some of those cables from
the s-band to the rfg itself and
installing caps as those will be
reinstalled in the future once the rfg
is replaced
still finishing the last
reason it's not
chatting as I expected
we copy
and one cab is installed on J1
the other one yes
looking for the better alignment here
wake up
and Sultan if it's uh if it gives you a
little more work space you can take the
hook off of the cap that you have
installed
hey both cabs installed
full fist
using the hooks
nicely done so you can release those
hooks and now Caddy's going to go back
to the crew lock bag
and then when your the cool lock bag you
can pick up two large small reps and
you'll be handing one of those over to
Steve and we can have Steve start to
drive bolts uh while Sultan continues to
tack down the cables
[Applause]
foreign
just a reminder for you
um that you do have the uh the page in
your cuff if you want to take a look at
the orientation but in general if you
look at the bolts the middle jacking
bolt is Bolt e
and then just to the left of that is f
and f is going to be the first one that
you do and then you're going to go
basically one left one right two left
two right all the way to the ends
yep that is good and then I hope we
won't need to know this but if you look
to the left of the leftmost bolt and to
the right of the rightmost bolt is where
you'd see the spring plungers kind of
perpendicular to the bolts pretty small
little spring plungers
those guys
yeah that's a good good spot
currently we're limiting
and one more orientation note for you
Steve when you go to remove it I know we
talk about this a lot in the conferences
but the motion that you'll want to do is
kind of a yawing motion where you would
push slightly with your right and pull
with your left and then vice versa so
just a real slight yaw onto the rfg as
you pull
stupid
flat don't lift it till it clears
and uh we should be able to pull it
basically straight back out
yep we agree with those words
I think I got enough oh here
to get it out
I think you're right Steve
yep just waiting on the
laundry I mean the uh Barcelo
this view from NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen's helmet camera again this is
Bowen's eighth spacewalk
using his handheld camera to take some
photos of the hardware and maybe even
earth below the International Space
Station is currently flying at 260
statute miles over Paraguay
they have the small hook
let me get that in place
they have a small hook on
at least the fire trucks
the electric is going on the hierarchy
yeah we see that the large small is on
the rfg so for sultan uh you can move
back to the crew lock bag and actually
we need a uh actually not quite yet so
we're gonna have you secure the
stanchion cables P1 and P9 to the
stanchion with a wire tie and then you
can Stow the cap keeper there and crew
lock bag one
and for Steve we are ready to drive the
bolts uh just a reminder around the rfg
to watch for Sharp edges your PGT
settings are Bravo One counter two
here
sorry
um
[Applause]
defense is good
and 41
7 volts
sound right
41.17 volts
anyone looking for what now
you want to say Bravo One counter two
brother one
o'clockwise
two and the fifth Bolt from the left of
the fourth full from the right
yep so it'll be the fourth Bolt from the
left will be our first one so F1 it's
going to be one to the left of the
jacking Bolt
okay so remembered a through a from the
right
okay one to the left of the jacket bolts
and I'm starting a homicer that's
correct and you should expect about 6.8
to 12.8 turns
okay that's the work
First Multiple
again Steve Bowen will release eight of
these structural bolts
he's using the PGT or the pistol grip
tool it's essentially a drill
and it helps for him to be in the
articulating portable foot restraint
that's mounted to the Canada arm 2 so
that he has some uh the heel coils
coming out it is loose and clear now
though
it's been clear
um
uh foxtrot
so ready for Delta
copy we are ready for Delta
that was
12.0 turns
copy 12.0
5 to going for Delta
concur
having a stable footing having stable
footing during these turns keeps Bowen
from rotating with the drill
all right
that was 12.0 turns as well
copy 12.0 on both Delta so your gopher
block goal third from the left
turn from the left and work
if you look it's clear as well
and another 12 turns
all right
copy another 12 turns for black golf
your next will be block Charlie third
from the right
there we go we got 10.4 terms there
and Charlie
and now I'm over to hotel
we Concur and copy 10.4 and Charlie and
the hotel
onto hotels
good words bolt Bravo and we copied 10.5
on bullet Hotel
we're now four hours since the start of
today's space walk Steve Bowen now
helping release eight bolts
that will help remove the rfg the radio
frequency group ncgl cables you want
them anywhere in the station
you can go anywhere onto that stanchion
and so that they're secure and clear of
the RFC removal path
and 12 turns
and now
and
Sultan just to clarify my last we want
those cables tacked down to anywhere
that's on the same structure as the uh
as the rfg
is going to be on the same statue that's
getting the rfg
copy
that's turning on me sorry about that
somewhere around 12 30.
all right
also
and we copied that you're on to Alpha
foreign
turns there
let's check all the springs
um
and we copy all the bolts and uh
trying to figure out which one's right
and um
this one and
let's go for sure golf might be worth
another turn or two if that's okay
and Steve we are good with that if you
want to put a couple of turns into golf
that they're all seen out
they're all pushed back
okay
I think I'm ready for Echo
okay and we're gonna stand by one and
get Sultan in a position to monitor
Owen has released all eight structural
Bolts from the radio frequency group
and so Sultan we'd like you to move into
position to see the after side of the
rfg during removal
reminder for both of you is that after
the center jacking bolt is released we
only want to pull the rfg towards Steve
not up
and to be aware of sharp edges on the
stanchion mounting plate and the rfg
base once that rfg is removed
I feel like a coffee Hall and uh excuse
me
a second excuse to position yourself
[Music]
okay um
this view from Sultan al-niadi's helmet
camera who's moving into position to
help with the removal of the rfg
Bowen will remove one more bolt known as
the jacking Bolt
the hardware would then only be in soft
dock
and if you're okay if they're okay with
this I'd like to move the big hook
in my right hand side uh just to make it
easier when I go to grab
the uh
you are going to move that
thank you
Sultan for your positioning we
specifically want you to look at the
after side of the rfg where that soft
dot catch is and monitor it tracking
thanks
to your position on myself here
give me a second no worries and we will
have time to tack down those cables once
the rft is removed
okay yes view of the rfg you are good to
release
okay and we Concur and Steve just one
note you're about uh eight minutes to a
sunset if you need to reconfigure
anything before you have your hands full
I think I'll be okay
okay so for releasing the rfg center
jacking bolt um you are go to release
that it's the same settings Bravo One
counterclockwise two and you're
expecting about 24.5 to 30 and a half
turns
you're 24 to 30 and a half turns
throw in once
all right getting turns
they talked out at
4.64 turns
at 12.
1 pounds
and we copy standby one
step through for the first step is
terrifying the smaller structural bolts
are fully released
a good job of doing that but let's see
if there's any restrictions
all right Steve as you can imagine this
puts us in a crib sheet so we are going
to run you through the steps here the
first thing we want you to do is then
you got to give a good call but just
re-verify that all of the structural
bolts are fully released that they're
and they're spring-loaded and will free
should free Spin and pop up
all right let me
put my
PT away and I'll double check all those
okay
and Sultana as he drove that jacket did
you see any movement on the soft.catch
negative to me it was the same and uh I
didn't see any appearance uh potion
yeah everything seems loose
okay copy
all right and I think everything's loose
good good spring on each one of them
obviously because that's hard to tell
when you can't turn so they all seem to
spin actually
okay Steve so we're going to have you
re-verify that the socket is fully
engaged and we're going to reattempt a
release with the same settings Bravo One
counter two
Hey Brother one counter two
two
it is fully seated
and folks are
with a
two register for
we copy it torqued out standby one
and we're going to talk about this for
just a minute
okay
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and United
Arab Emirates astronaut Sultan al-nayadi
are on their first spacewalk together
the fourth of the Year quite yet but
just for your awareness that we're
talking about it because with the low
turn count that we did get on the
jacking bolt tells us that it's still
engaged in the ass section so we're
talking about our next steps I agree
yeah
the spacewalk began four hours and 10
minutes ago and the astronauts are on
their second major task which is to
remove the rfg the radio frequency group
from the s-band antenna the rfg
is the computer and electronics that
control the s-band system
Bowen just released eight structurable
structural bolts and is working to
remove the one jacking Bolt
Bowen was uh
able to execute fewer turns than were
expected when using the pistol grip tool
have you put your PGT on Bravo One
clockwise too so we're going to
basically drive it in a little bit and
then reattempt a nominal release torque
so we're going to drive the bolt only
one turn on Bravo One clockwise too
okay Bravo One
clockwise too
do one turn
good words
that's fully seated
at 12.0 as well
and no point
004 turns
okay we understand that it only went
0.004 and torqued out checking
and we're about 20 seconds to hand over
so you might want to take a picture
we're gonna have to talk about this for
a sec
ah
this view from Mission Control Houston
as we are in a satellite Handover during
this spacewalk teams here are
troubleshooting the removal of the rfg
the radio frequency group that Bowen is
working on
he's using the pistol grip tool to
remove a jacking Bolt
that has given fewer turns than expected
teams previously have outlined several
different ways they can troubleshoot
this so they are working through those
right now
back already
we are back with you after the Handover
but we are still chatting
foreign
well we're waiting for words you can go
ahead and finish tacking down those
cables if you'd like
all right thanks
uh
foreign
okay Steve here's the plan we talked
earlier about the kind of the yaw motion
to wiggle the rfg so this is where
you're going to gently push on your left
and pull on your right and then vice
versa to see if there's any bit of Play
It's really critical right here that we
don't go up and down so you only want to
go left and right with a slight yaw
and once you've worked that a little bit
we're going to reattent let's see no
play
copy we understand no play
right left
copy we're going to have you reattempt
one more time the nominal release Bravo
One counter two
Bravo won counterclockwise too
good read back
oh
[Applause]
no joy I got the 0.1
4.4 pounds four pounds
okay we copy Steve stand by one
coming up on four hours and 20 minutes
into the spacewalk again Steve Bowen
working to remove the rfg the radio
frequency group part of the s-band
antenna
one jacking bolt is being quite stubborn
teams here are helping troubleshoot next
steps for Bowen as he uses the pistol
grip tool to release the rfg from its
stanchion
and Steve just letting you know we are
still talking about it uh this is kind
of a unique case that puts us in between
a few things so we'll get words back to
you in just a minute
I understand
I am sure you do
the
and Sultan we still don't have our next
steps but it may include the pry bar so
just to save a little time we'd like you
to retrieve the pry bar from crew lock
bag one
I understand that I think I'll stand by
for those cables because I don't have a
good reach under this tension but I've
got a few without touching it
good plan Sultan thanks
foreign
and for both crew while we continue to
talk about this so we'd like to take a
glove and have check and uh for your
awareness that's a time-based one you're
about four and a half hours pet
coffee
try
and for 82 no change on the gloves of
the same and habits that's right
copy thank you both
yeah
you're going to look you can get that
pry bar into back there
I think so yes
okay
it hasn't backed off at either but I can
throw anywhere
but will it work without uh yeah
removing the Jack and balls I don't know
you guys are talking about what
everybody down here is talking about
that uh stand by one
stop
um
okay here's the next steps that we're
going to try Sultan you guys are kind of
reading our minds up there we're going
to have you go to the AFT side of the
rfg with that pry bar
and what we're going to do is we're
going to line the pry bar up in the
middle of the rfg with a small end and
we'll let us know if you can get if
there's a lip or like a catch you want
to put the the kind of the tooth of the
pry bar down and then so that when you
lift up on it it'll push forward on the
rfg only in the direction of the bolts
I think I have a small lip here
and uh
myself and that's good
transition and then
oh
Fireball can be precisioned okay and
just to let you know both the overall
plan we're going to see if we can get
any push on that rfg once you see any
movement at all
then you can stop what you're doing and
we'll try that bolt again and again we
want to make sure that you're in this as
close to the center of the rfg as you
can so we don't side load it there is an
alignment guide right in the middle of
the rfg so you're gonna have to go just
to one side of that
and when you do put the force into it
it's going to be a slow steady uh Force
we don't want any impulsing
nice coffee
yeah in just a little further words we
don't want any kind of impulse hits on
the on it uh and it's a
the limit is about 75 pounds but just a
nice smooth turn on the Crowbar or the
pry bar to see if you can get that
pushed
I think it's positioned very well but my
orientation is not great so
flying
uh
four four so I did push a little bit
and it did not move
okay Sultan and you can reposition uh
reposition a DC fit to make sure we're
getting a good
Force important impulse or press
smoothly onto the app side of it
push forward
yeah just making sure in that case
that's going to be a lot easier to push
up and we do not want to push up at all
but yeah I'm not thinking this
directions
and Sultan if it's easier at the work
site you can release one of the it looks
like there's two Rats on the pry bar
okay
it's not moving them
I'm trying to force is too much
okay we uh we copy full-time negative
motion nothing
okay
stand by
e
okay Steve we are going to have you try
one more time
um Bravo One counter two on the jacking
bolt Sultan we want you to stay clear of
the F side and just observe we don't
want the pry bar in there at all
okay
Morocco
one seven o'clockwise too
hopefully
all right I got the port one five turns
out of 12.4
okay we copy
okay Steve we're going to try one more
time driving in the bolt one turn uh so
it's going to be Bravo One clockwise two
one Turn Only
[Music]
3.1 volt
let's see if I track one turn
yeah and that's correct uh driving in
clockwise one turn
Ed out
[Applause]
0.11 turns
4.0
okay Stephen we're gonna go Bravo One
counter two again to reattent
s
level one
that's likewise too
all right
compounds
[Music]
yeah we copy that Steve and uh we're
going to talk about it for another
minute
absolutely
we're over four and a half hours into
today's space walk
our two astronauts Steve Bowen this is
from his helmet camera view right here
and Sultan al-nayadi have completed the
first major task of the day which was to
Route some cables that will be used on
future irosas some rollout solar arrays
that will be installed later this year
as well as to secure some multi-layer
insulation around the hardware in that
area
they've moved on to the second major
task of the day which is to remove the
rfg the radio frequency group from the
s-band antenna
Bowen has removed
okay Gentlemen The Next Step that we're
going to take is we're going to
coordinate those two movements so Sultan
we're going to have you place the pry
bar where you had it before and Steve
you're going to reattempt a to disengage
with a nominal torque of Bravo One
counter two and then coordinate your
movements so that Sultan is pushing on
the back at the same time that Steve is
driving the bolt
all right for level one counterclockwise
too
and uh sorry if you're ready
okay hold on let me go
get clear
all right
three three one go
all right that's worked out again
and no motion here
[Music]
we copy standby one
the rfg was not designed to be removed
during a spacewalk
and there's one bolt that's giving the
astronauts trouble right now so teams on
the ground are helping them step through
some additional procedures that may help
them remove this piece of hardware
the goal is for the team to remove the
hardware bring it inside the space
station and eventually return it to
Earth for refurbishment before it is
launched back again
quite a bit
determen I'd like to next step is a
public procedures is
going to hold are concerned out here is
the force that's holding the box they're
still going to be there
again
so we're thinking about other options
that are more unpublished
I want to wish to be to use a pylar to
try to lift the back end of the box
um
foreign
over and we are still talking about this
one
okay
foreign
we are still with you both and we're
still talking it
okay
again this view live inside Mission
Control Houston as NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen and UAE astronaut Sultan al-niadi
are on a spacewalk today outside the
International Space Station
right now they're troubleshooting the
removal of the rfg the radio frequency
group
this is the brains essentially of the
orbital replacement unit on the
s-band system it contains the computer
and electronics that control it
we're looking to remove this piece of
Hardware that you can see from NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen's helmet camera
bring it inside the space station for
eventual refurbishment
play PBA so before we do the lifting up
on the pry bar we're going to try doing
the sort of a nudge forward
okay The Next Step that we're going to
have you both try is a combination of
the pry bar on the back with Sultan and
then the wiggle on the front with you
Steve we're thinking that we need to
overcome a little bit of distinction
between the rfg and the mounting plate
and so some gentle yawning at the same
time as we use the pry bar in the back
To Be steady
with a steady push
three three
okay one position okay we'll start
yelling
I left hey
no motion are you seeing anything nope
okay just steady push on it I am fat
looks like it
you can see your reflection in here by
the way
the driver
see nothing
continuing to y'all
okay we uh we unders we've copied no
motion so the next step uh Sultan I know
we we have talked about not lifting up
the rfg but uh uh in stuck in the
position that we're at that's kind of
our next specs option so Sultan we're
gonna have you flip the pry bar around
and put the long Edge just under the rfg
and gently try to lift slightly up on
the rfg and what we're trying to do is
exercise some of that stiction between
the rfg and the stanchion plate
like copy if it doesn't work
I'm sorry
and just to clarify no no action for you
on this one Steve
I'm just standing back there watching
on both sides
and Sultan those are good motions and
we'll just have you continue that all
the way out to the edges of the box
and Steve just so you can be ready after
he's exercised the full length of the
rfg we'll have you attempt to re-release
on Bravo One counter two one more time
thank you
and you guys are about three minutes
those are good words and uh you're about
three minutes from a sunrise and just so
you know we are watching the timeline we
have a few more minutes to troubleshoot
before we'll have to move on
okay
that's right it's an old stations at the
back
go Steve
okay
all right and Steve you're our go-to
re-attempt the center jacking bolt Bravo
One counter two
o'clockwise too
instead of Jackie
Greenway
12 points
stand by one
by DVA that's our understanding
and if we pursue the higher torque
settings instead of warning for them
okay big picture on the potential next
steps we're not taking the action yet
but there's a couple of associated words
here so the next step is going to be to
increase the PGT to Bravo 7.
and note that the PGT will only it'll
ramp up the torque that it puts into the
bolt until it starts moving
there is a warning Associated that this
is going to be above the failure torque
of the bolt increasing in the torque may
break the bolt presenting loose hardware
and potential sharp edges at the bolt
interface on both the rfg and the statue
so be prepared for font with a small
trash bag and avoid contact with the
bolt interface
coffee okay no copies
and stand by one I will call you when we
want to take that next step
s
okay
coming up on four hours and fifty five
zero minutes into the spacewalk we have
an orbital sunrise on the International
Space Station
station buying 262 statute miles over
the Sea of Japan
this view coming from Steve Bowen's
helmet camera NASA astronaut on his
eighth spacewalk today teams here on the
ground are working to troubleshoot a
stuck bolt on this rfg radio frequency
group that the teams are trying to
remove
thank you
and we are still talking about it before
we take this next step
absolutely
again
questions
a little more forward just off the
button
another good one thank you
provide
yourself
okay Steven Sultan here's the plan Steve
we are going to have you do Bravo 7
counter two Sultan at the same time
we're going to have you gently push with
a pry bar on the back side
and keep in mind that the PGT is only
going to put in as much force as needed
to start driving that bolt so if you get
an indication that the bolt is broken as
in its free spinning and the box is not
moving anywhere go ahead and stop Sultan
as soon as you see motion on the box
stop pushing with a pry bar
as well all right
Bravo seven
o'clockwise
correct
position on this
I'm getting the most stroke it broke
this
yep and we see that
first course
I'm not make sure I catch the washers
and Steve did you see where the bolt had
went or did that stay captive on your
PGT
yeah I haven't checked the end of the
PGT yet
all right Kathy
what's the end of the pgp
repaired part of my trash bags
unless it was going uh forward Venus
Direction
and
it wasn't hitting anything they bring
Venus and forwards to the station
there is one on your left
okay we copy your track in Fulton
okay we're going to need a minute to
talk about this one uh if you see any
loose items uh please let us know where
you see them going if you don't catch
them we'll take those words and uh we're
going to talk about this one for a
minute
nope I had it
and then there is a washer just on top
of a few pyramids
hold on
all right it's in the trash bag where's
another one that's right top of your
helmets you can't reach it
moving slowly away
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that was expected
um
and uh once you get things stowed if you
give us a good glove and hap check do
the sharp edges or sorry glove check do
the sharp edges and we're talking about
next steps
good
um
might be a small
off on the RTD on my right glove
yourself
and it hasn't penetrated RTD
I need to get inside well if I need to
take a look at that later on okay we
copy the spot on the RTV on the right
glove and you believe it's limited to
just the RTV
okay good word Steve we're obviously
talking about this one a little bit big
picture we're at five hours of pet
I understand
work but we'll see you the way the ball
broken that's the alleviated any of the
pressure on the system
okay
and we are five hours into today's
spacewalk this view from helmet camera
of NASA astronaut Steve Bowen
he and Sultan anayati UAE astronaut are
working to remove the Earth
to put some pressure on the back of the
box while Steve we're going to have you
pull it you can do the gentle Left Right
wiggle but we're going to see if this if
by chance uh this might have been
released
all right
we're doing Rusty all right three two
one did you study I'm going left right
left right still no motion
don't push left right left
okay we're getting nothing there
we copy
foreign
the two astronauts have been working to
remove the rfg the radio frequency group
however there was one bolt that was
stuck and not allowing them to remove it
from the stanchion that bolt broke
during troubleshooting procedures
and teams are now looking
through future steps for the rest of the
spacewalk
quite a bit
of stuff but with the hammer we think
the center bolt if it's still engaged
although that was just sort of
okay okay
okay
Sultan we're going to have you head back
to the staging bag in the airlock
and we're going to have you pick up the
Eva Hammer we think that we might be
able to loosen up the cling of the
jacking bolt with some the use of the
Eva Hammer again that's in the staging
bag and airlock
all right coffee
teams continue troubleshooting
procedures here in Mission Control
Houston and relaying those up to the
astronauts Sultana al-niadi is going to
retrieve another tool to attempt in
helping remove the rfg from its
stanchion
the eight structural bolts released by
Bowen all moved as planned however the
one Center jacking bolt would not remove
and eventually sheared off
and a reminder this Hardware was not
planned to be modified or serviced
during a spacewalk so
um
the goal overall though is to have it
removed brought inside the space station
and returned to Earth refurbishment
ahead of another launch to the station
this Hardware is part of the s-band
system which is our critical command and
data link to and from the station
obviously we have redundancy in those
Services otherwise we wouldn't have the
communications that we do today
foreign
in this view from one of the cameras
external on the space station we have a
great view of the canadarm 2 on which
Steve Bowen is attached
foreign
at the top of your screen that beautiful
blue below is the North Pacific Ocean
the space station traveling 261 statute
miles above and approximately 17 500
miles per hour or five miles per second
meanwhile emirati astronaut Sultana
nayati on his first spacewalk which is
also the first spacewalk for an
astronaut from the United Arab Emirates
has made his way back to the airlock to
retrieve an additional tool to assist in
troubleshooting with removal of the rfg
and your status for you Steve uh as you
hang out there it does look like still
tons in the staging bag in the airlock
and we're going to use the Eva hammer on
that soft.catch that's on the back of
the rfg
it was we got to cut something and now
we're going to use a hammer uh and and
when we he uses a hammer on the back
we're going to let you kind of Wiggle
the rfg with the handles
I will try
hey Steve as you're sitting there we're
talking about some of the fog that was
generated can you give us an idea of how
many pieces of fud you think we're
tracking a bolt and a washer did you see
anything else
well I don't I've got the full head
there were a few washers
that I saw
um I didn't think I saw much of anything
else
but I caught the Bullhead
and uh the two washers I had I thought I
had one but uh
appeared on me I didn't see anything
else
it's pretty quick okay it was it was a
great catch actually the uh so we did
see you get the bolt head
um and so we're just kind of thinking
through where the washers could be a
specific uh specifically because you're
close to the arm did you happen to see
what direction the washers went in
I'll kind of tracked both of them
initially
um if one of them was sitting on top of
my head for a while but it was drifting
behind us
uh earlier after he said I couldn't get
it
I agree uh two washers the first one was
immediately behind Steve and moving
towards the arms the second one I it was
moving slowly with uh selling station
um
orientation
and a brief loss of signal with the
International Space Station as teams
were discussing with the astronauts some
of the pieces from the radio frequency
group that came apart
whenever trying to remove it from its
stanchion
we will regain communication shortly
once satellites have handed over
meanwhile we are now five hours and 11
minutes into today's spacewalk
a recap so far the first main task has
been completed that was to Route some
cables and secure some
head toward you see
okay we copied that the thermal coupler
is closed and if you get a safer handle
check
is to be closed now
sorry yes we're with you on voice and we
don't quite have your video yet
down
copy both safer handles down thanks
difficult
and Sultan as you get back out to the
work site we're going to have you take
it the same position on the AFT side of
the rfg
when we use the hammer we're going to be
specifically using it on the soft dot
catch
okay I'm back in position
okay copy so you can see kind of out by
your left hand is the soft dot catch
it's that little gold square that sticks
out from uh just above the stanchion
and we want you to position
um so that you can hit that with the
hammer but that if you happen to miss it
your bias down toward the stanchion side
there's a thin piece of mli that
protects that stanchion and we do not
want to strike the box with a hammer so
we want to make sure that you're in a
good position to get the soft dot catch
or slightly biased below it
work
do you have a specific side of the
hammer rubber side or the metal side
and Sultan yeah the the black side on
there the rubber Edge
the non-metal side
moving I will see any motion
okay wait Kathy
this view from the helmet camera of
Sultan al-nayani
and Sultan to verify that neither the
soft catch nor the Box are moving
is wiggling
up and down but not always enough
and that is my that is like a lot
dark line
it's for an alignment and that is not
moving as well
no forward motion
okay we copy
let's view a rare use of the Eva hammer
as the astronauts attempt to remove the
rfg the radio frequency group from its
stanchion
try and go ahead and Stow that tool you
just put in the crew lock bag or on your
mjbs whichever you prefer and we are
talking steps to uh
reinstall the rfg
coffee
because it's an iterative process to
reinstall these we'll start with one
we'll start with the left one do five
turns again the rfg that the astronauts
are working to removed was never
intended to be serviced during a
spacewalk
Steve Bowen was able to remove the eight
structural bolts but had issues with the
one jacking bolt still keeping the
Hardware attached to its stanchion
that bolt head sheared off during
troubleshooting procedures
continue cleaning up that
work site there uh Steve we're going to
have you redrive the bolts in so you
know this is going to be one of those
iterative bolt processes where you're
going to drive it for five turns and
then we're going to look at the running
torque and then give you a final torque
the first bolt we're going to start with
is the far left bolt bolt Juliet
your settings are Bravo One
clockwise too
and we want you to drive for five turns
and it's important to not release the
pg2 trigger until five turns and then
let us know the Peak Running torque
okay
all the way to the left at Juliet
good read back
okay
all right starting service
going clockwise
because the rfg will
and I got an actual running torque of
zero I'm not sure if we take a look see
if it's fit
this looks like it's fit at all
we copy well maybe it has it doesn't
seem as far out as the others it has
definitely gone in I just have zero
running for it
must have just better
we copy standby
the rfg was unable to be removed as
intended today
therefore Steve Bowen will redrive the
structural bolts too and hold it in
place
clockwise but he's also got to change
the MCL setting to 2.5
okay Steve with zero running torque
we're gonna have you put the PGT in
Ratchet clockwise
and the MTL at 2.5 foot pounds
that's it clockwise it moved the MCL to
2.5
all right ntl is a 2.5
animation clockwise you ready for me to
go to motor
yeah so you should just at this point
just ratchet uh clockwise
you want me to try and just ratchet this
thing in okay
he's probably out about another five
and it will probably be an additional
five turn Steve
Anderson I'm not sure would have got for
sure
go ahead
yeah I see that you're cleaning up the
bags for your steps we're talking about
the cables and I if
I think that you had the uh wire tie
around the cables but you had not tacked
them down to a hand draw is that correct
that's affirmative yes
okay if you can get those stowed on a
stanchion with a wire tie you can and
otherwise we'll have to reinstall them
outside of
fence are we floating the tent anyway
checking
removal sir
I I think I'm breaking torque yep
that both of them
I don't know how many extra turns it was
probably the five
okay Steve uh we're gonna do the same
thing on bolt Alpha uh so we're going to
start in Bravo one you have to reset the
MTL to 12 foot pounds
and we'll go clockwise too
correction 30.5 hey FPL
back to 30.5 on the MCL
that's affirmative and for sultan
um we'll end up kind of cleaning up
everything back there so your call on
the cables if you can tack them down out
of the way we will end up reinstalling
that mli
I think if I just
plug them under the rfg they'll be
secured their cap and we can cover with
the 10 30 secure
the undertones again
we are good with that plan sultan
a lot harder than gloves than it is
all right 30.5
all right good config so we're Bravo One
clockwise two 30.5 you're gonna go on
bolt Alpha five turns
both are also fighters number one talk
was two
um
all right manual Rockets
and I'm gonna go to motor
I'm a motor
Bravo One clockwise two
plug bolt Alpha 5 turbo good settings
good bolts
professors
5.06 terms
0.0
okay we copy and the good news is you
can now just go to Alpha One and drive
it in to torque
that is going back to sdl for all Alpha
One listen to Alpha
certified Alpha One
and uh clockwise two still
affirmative clockwise too
good words
here it comes
Bowen is now driving the eight
structural bolts he was able to release
earlier
in removing the rfg we got stuck on the
all right
three four three pounds
at 4.90 turns
we copy 2.3 and 4.9 and next we're going
to go to the second in from the left
bolt Hotel Bravo One clockwise two five
turns
Bravo won
the Bravo
clockwise
okay and Steve actually stand by one uh
we're gonna we don't need to do the
iterative on this bolt so you can go
ahead and set it at two Alpha One
clockwise two to drive the whole way
hey back to Alpha One
clockwise two they're driving all the
way
all right
here it comes
uh whatever letter this is second from
the left
and starting turns
out
and it's a little looking decal
s
[Applause]
Cal pass
good LED tests
3.1 volts
Okay so
Alpha One
buckwife two
good settings and pretty correct
all right
perfect but
yeah but this is this this will just
allows them to have to reset the PGC
wants it all right I got a good torque
2.5 pounds 5.23 turns
okay copy uh we would like the same
thing on bolt Bravo second one from the
right
Bravo Alpha One clockwise two
Alpha One clockwise two both Bravo
Bowen continues to
to drive the structural bolts he was
able to release earlier today
however that Center jacking bolt which
is now missing was sheared off
and the rfg
was still attached to its stanchion
therefore it will not be brought inside
today
redriving these bolts allows the rfg to
remain secure outside the station
s
10.77 turns
okay wake up at 10.77 stand by one
um
okay Steve uh we're going to have you do
next is that uh those the second three
that we just drove straight in uh with
Alpha One uh we're going to take your
PGT back to ratchet and we're going to
wreckage counterclockwise and we're
going to have you release it half a turn
and then after that we're going to have
you ratchet uh all the way in just like
you did on the far left bolt so the
first thing you want to do right now is
put your cgt in Ratchet counterclockwise
and we're going to release half a turn
on each of the last three bolts you did
counterclockwise
and I will
release those three bolts I just drove
one half of the turn
that's good words this is just to save
you from having to go back and forth
between the regular and Ratchet
I appreciate it
all right
great turns you can do that on the other
two as well
after
and last one
all right
dmtl now
okay so now you'll go ratchet clockwise
with MTL 2.5
and Sultan while you're waiting there uh
we'd like you to take your camera and
get as many pictures of the back side of
that rfg at different angles that you
can
sure so we're about to clockwise
it feels at 2.5
and I'm gonna
about to give another half turn or so
okay
yep that was the phone
uh but they're a little maybe a little
bit more
and they're coming back over here the
second last bolts
is the last of the four
foreign
guys those four bolts are all manually
set
to work at two and a half
all right good words thanks for that
Steve you can Stow your PGT
um
and Steve you can release that large
small rip
that's complete
big picture
personal time we'll pick up on page 18.
click up in step four
steps
we are 5 hours and 36 minutes into
today's Space Walk This view from the
helmet camera of NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen you're looking at the rfg the
radio frequency group we were unable to
remove that from its stanchion today the
plan was to bring it inside for future
refurbishment
so the astronauts just bolted it back in
place will remain safe outside the space
station
okay big picture we are going to be
moving a few pages ahead in the
procedure Sultan will be working esp2
cleanup and Steve you're going to be
working
ssrms cleanup and so let me know if this
is a good egress position for you or if
you'd like to go to the published apfr
egress position in which case we'll hand
you back to robo
I didn't get out here I'm not sure I can
remove the APR from here but I'll get
out and then I'll
okay copy
and for sultan we are going to be
reinstalling that mli so you can
retrieve the pre-staged large small rut
that used to tie that back it looks like
you're already in work and we'll be
putting that back over the rfg with a 10
quarter turn fasteners
the astronauts are stepping into their
cleanup procedures
they're definitely gonna need to get a
different position to remove the
uh
take your car
let me get my weight feather off of it
I am still kick each other to it
Steve Owen on the left wearing the red
striped suit is removing the
articulating portable foot restraint
from the Canon arm too
on the right is going to be recovering
the hardware that the teams were working
to remove with that multi-layer
insulation to keep it protected and for
uh for Steve if uh actually Steve
orselton uh whoever's in a best position
to do it uh we also would like some
still photos of the front side of that
rfg where the broken bolt is
and for Steve if you could give us a
look at the Lee in and around the Lee we
know that those two washers kind of
floated off we just want to make sure
that they're not somewhere obvious
around the end of our arm
okay
uh can you Google you know
you want me to get closer I'll find out
on your uh if you're far
okay and Steve it's your choice if you
want to climb out there or wait till you
take the apfr off
all right well there I am I'm out on it
I don't know if that helps that much
pretty good shot with your helmet cam
actually
that's what I was hoping if I can get a
I want to get a more direct on view
though
not sure if that's a little bit better
could have them reposition I could look
straight down the barrel if you want
yeah and uh your call Steve if you don't
see anything any fod in that area then
that's uh that's good with us
I don't see any fraud I can't check the
well that would have been in the wrong
direction with the bounce
can't see the uh
the wires
that are immediately next to me whatever
her face that is at this point I said
app
yeah I can't see the app why everything
else is clear
okay that's uh see we're ready to
support GCA if you need it
all right
um
actually at least if I can reach my
to get this thing out
uh Woody I don't know if you guys can
pitch
the end effector
half
I'm not sure what direction that is
very coordinates and then I can look
straight down the barrel with the key if
there's anything on the stairs
in the uh the other mechanism
okay that's a good report Steve we're
going to get you moving uh off the arm
and uh if you want the uh Frank to move
the arm to the publish APF our egress
and removal position we just want you to
be aware that your safety tether base is
still there
[Applause]
I agree so uh
and uh Woody I'm ready for you to move
the arm to the established
e-position
for that now for awareness that's just
about 22 centimeters station Nader
okay I really need to come
ahead
hmm
bricks are off okay I need a
um
because it was 20 centimeters that
and then 20 centimeters
uh 40 centimeters starboard
coffee 20 apps and 40 starboards and am
I that correct
I'll make that
sport I need it toward me I'm sorry
good motion
what else devotion that was me
what have you got
you see we're going to begin GCA and
we're going to start with your 20
centimeters of station Nader motion
starting motions
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg
40 centimeters of station Port starting
Rush thank you
hoberg is inside
View just up there for a minute
can you continue another 20 continue
[Applause]
10 to your 20.
that's a good position to stop there the
whole position
all right and if I can get uh 25
centimeters app
s 28 centimeters station aft
copy thanks for watching the clearing
Steve
as you can stop motion there that should
do it I hope
copyhole position
taken care of here
we copy GCA complete
brakes are on all right thank you
okay and before we get into your tether
swamp a couple more words for sultan and
the cleanup you're going to do those 10
quarter turn Fasteners and then you're
going to be looking to Stow the large
small red back into crew lock bag one
and then we'll get ready for a crew lock
bag one inventory
for Steve we are ready for your safety
tether swap so when you have a local
down I will redo the steps when you're
in position
occasionally
a little bit better to think here
[Music]
we go get close by the lot
and this is going through my left
earrings benders
yes
I will just do that directly
and let's do it though I gotta pick up
the green hook
and I'll transfer it out to
I gotta get my
if it is behind me
foreign
might be able to help out with that real
Sultan if you look to your left
you might be able to help Steve out with
Israel
sorry
done by Steve okay
remove the body up now
three times between your legs yeah
good afternoon
if you're not perfect thank you
so make it fall out easier
all right great job so Steve your first
uh your first step is going to be to
either lock or tether to the green
tether reel
and put a hook on
for real
okay A little large threat on it okay
you can retrieve your green hook and
you're going to attach the green hook
with the gate closed and hook locked to
your red tether rail
all right
custom work
ah
there's green hook
is the red
wheel
that's complete
Kappy and we want to lock that one
copy of the green Hook is locked you now
go to release your yellow Hook from the
ssrms handrail tether point
all right we'll leave the yellow hook
ers
knock off the
wheel
ah
stronauts Steve Bowen and Sultan
al-nayadi are cleaning up their work
sites
all the audio is reinstalling the
multi-layer insulation over the s-band
antenna group
we're about 45 seconds to a Handover and
Steve once you get your yellow Hook from
the ssrms handrail tether Point you're
going to be attaching it to the green
reel and ensuring that it's locked
Bobby
we're in another Handover of the
tracking data and relay satellite system
the astronauts aboard the International
Space Station began their spacewalk five
hours and 53 minutes ago
this is planned six and a half hour
spacewalk
the first major task was completed
flawlessly when the astronauts routed
the irosa Cable Bundle
they also installed and secured some
multi-layer insulation
on The Mod kits where future irosas will
be installed
the second major task today was to
remove the rfg the
radio frequency group from its stanchion
this is part of the s-band antenna
however the uh
crew ran into some trouble with one bolt
that was stuck and eventually sheared
off and were unable to remove it from
the stanchion therefore they re-secured
it and have now moved into their cleanup
tasks
uh
foreign
okay good word Steve we understand
yellow Hook is locked and on your green
Rail and you unlocked it so you do have
good safety tether pack
all right I understand I have a good
safety quarterback
here
all right Steve your next step is going
to be to retrieve the apfr from the arm
and throw it on your beer keep
all right
and Sultan we see you working the mli we
do have one Delta step for you on the
mli we're gonna have to secure that
clamshell down so when you're at a
stopping point let me know and I will
give you words to go do that
foreign
this is a view from Steve Bowen's helmet
camera as he works to remove the
articulating portable foot restraint
from the cannon arm too
going to continue these cleanup steps
and head back inside
nice coffee
you are approaching six hours pet
all right
I might need you to do something here
and take the
apfr will take the arm
station port
I'll take a station forward
ticket station forward
uh
30 centimeters
and then
of course me
and that would be stationed
uh
begin GCA we're going to start with a
motion station forward 30 centimeters
and then we'll come station four thank
you
starting motion station forward
good motion give me a motion continue
to go
continue to another 20.
continue another 20.
10 to go
you can stop at that ten
okay copy Steve that's your 20. now uh
30 centimeters station port
yeah
space in court and then we'll uh
little stuff from there
all right
foreign
40 centimeters
TV copy additional four zero centimeter
station Port starting motion
pretty good motion
six hours since the start of the
spacewalk NASA astronaut Woody whoberg
inside the space station is maneuvering
the candid arm too
thank you the astronauts outside are
working through their cleanup tasks and
preparing to Ingress after those are
complete
do you think that's your 40. okay
stop saying didn't bring me station
video station at 30 centimeters
copy station aft three zero centimeters
starting motion
to go
and just stop at that 15.
and Steve that's your 30 centimeters
complete thank you perfect
on I'll take the yellow I mean the uh if
you're far out from here
see if we copied GCA complete
all right a weekend breaks are on your
go for apfr removal
all right Steve you can get the apfr
sultan and I'm ready for uh
perfect I have words for you so we're
going to have you take an AET from your
mws
and we're going to go over to the
clamshell mli so we basically need to
recreate the strap that we cut earlier
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're going to have you Loop the AET
through the clamshell handrail so it
can't be a hook to the handrail it's got
to be looped through and then hooked to
itself
and then you're going to take the hook
end of the AET and on the other side of
the rfg from where you're at there are
some there's some black seams along that
velcro seam and you're gonna you can
hook the AET to that
okay I don't see any black
um
yeah but it's just on the other side of
that if you translate around to your
left
I mean the stiff side
yeah good word so it's over on Steve's
side it's kind of that velcro seam it's
right along where that velcro seam was
that that you buttoned up when you put
it back on and there should be some
black loops
here
theater
[Music]
on that forward area
is removed
okay Steve that's going to go on your
brt and you're going to be heading out
to the Port City cart via the same path
that you took this way so all over the
lab to the Gap spanner and up the struts
and you'll be picking up that uh
Fairlane that you left with the AET
earlier on the lab struts
all right I'm putting that in work
order my tether for once
questions
and Steve as you translate we'd
appreciate if you double check the
Ingress Aid to make sure that it's
retracted
Earth
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
you can just position that hook on one
of those black tether loops
whichever one you think is the best fit
and then again the AET is going to get
looped through the clamshell handrail
and then hooked back to itself
I'm Stephen Sultan just for awareness
the robotic arm is going to be
maneuvering station forward away from
esp2 to a park position
thank you
foreign
starting motion station forward
okay okay adjustable equipment center is
installed in the clam shell
on one side and to the
back
move on the 10th
we have a few site all right good work
Sultan we saw the same thing we like
that config uh so we're going to have
you head back over to crew lock bag one
and there was a large small that you had
pre-staged outside of that we want to
make sure that's back on the crew lock
but I think Royal Crown but I need to do
two more Fasteners that I haven't done
the fourth side
together
and for big pictures Sultan when you go
back in three
and uh yes for Steve you're going back
into with three which is the top left
thank you
and your settings are six papa papa fox
six
fox six
okay
good words and for sultan as you get
back to their crew lock bag I'm going to
have you check a couple items we're not
going to do a full crew Block Bag
inventory but I'm going to have you
check off a couple items that we used on
the CBA
okay and uh
there a minute on your full View
Bowen and on the Audi continue cleanup
procedures during today's space walk
as you can see the articulating portable
foot restraint has been removed from the
Canon arm too
meanwhile al-niadi has been covering the
s-band antenna with the mli that was
removed prior to attempts to remove the
rfg from its stanchion
foreign
and six papa papa
six
if I could fill in place
okay copy Stephen can you just double
check the pitch knob is locked and it
can be depressed
Mark is locked it can be depressed
the caller
for the uh
rear saturation mechanism
uh it again gave me the indications that
it was
uh Watts black on black but
uh was not
and it wouldn't wouldn't stay in place
um
and it was
I actually took a try to take it back
out and pushed it back in to get his
gold black on black so it's it's in now
but I don't have high confidence in uh
collar on this one
it was difficult to move the caller okay
yeah we copy thanks for those words
Steve and we've got those notes down
um so at this point you are actually
going to give me a glove and half
inspection please
okay let me get this right off the apfr
first Sultan we want you to double check
on that crew lock bag that you picked up
the large small that we had pre-staged
on that handrail
Pharmacy it's uh goes to the bag again
copy and then we want you to verify that
the hammer and the pry bar in the are in
the crew lock bag
and the cool effect
as well okay copy and then the other
last two things we want to check is the
wire tie caddy and then the two wire
ties in series that you had put together
to use that we didn't use
okay
it is is inside just checking for the
foreign
[Music]
okay good word Sultan you're going to
put that on your brt and then we're
going to have you translate back over to
where you installed the AET and I'm
going to have you do one quick
adjustment on it on your way back to the
airlock
all right coffee and work
all right and my love to give my half a
straw
copy Steve so you can translate off of
the seated cart and as you do so please
depress the port see to break pedals
twice as you go by and then you can
translate to the Anchor hooks
airport feed a break
okay first reverse twice
and we copy the brick pedals thank you
let me get started as well
and Steve sure we'll take it as you go
by
e and we are about five minutes from
sunrise
yeah we'll look back to
upgrt ready for uh
I'm sure Elixir work
yeah so the AET we had you Loop one side
on the clam shell and then the other
side we said to hook it what we'd like
you to do is just take that side that
you hooked and unhook it and loop it
through just like you did the other side
so therefore both sides are looped
through and hooked back to the AET
itself
yeah
okay I see you thanks I'll do that now
foreign
reminder you're looking for mile marker
5760.
yeah I thought I could uh maybe I could
run down and there was other two bags
back in the crew locks yourself down one
less thing to do
how does that sound for a plan
yeah copy we're good with that plan
okay
okay look back to itself both sides
we appreciate that Sultan and so now you
can translate over to the airlock
okay
so as you get back to the airlock you
can coordinate how you guys want to get
things back in we have a crew lock bag 2
and crew lock bag three above the
airlock toolboxes and we have the GoPro
on the side of the crew lock
s
all right it's all done I'm right here
I can hand you down the back
oh
once you get let's just put your crew
lock bag in
I'll hand you these bags
this is Mission Control Houston we have
a Handover of our satellites that allow
us to communicate with the International
Space Station both astronauts Steve
Bowen and Sultan al-nayani have
completed the cleanup portion of today's
spacewalk they are now moving back
toward the quest airlock
review
they have a couple bags to retrieve that
will be stowed in the airlock
afterward both astronauts will close the
hatch once they have ingressed
the thermal cover
and we copy a thermal cover open and a
reminder you have three large small reps
on that d-ring extender one for each of
the crew lock bags one two and three
thanks
foreign
just for your awareness we're looking at
the scu's a good call by your crewmate
inside and just note that both of the
seus are kind of routed on the forward
side of the airlock so before you
Ingress you may want to move Steves onto
the outside of the airlock
s
[Music]
I'm just gonna wait before I Ingress uh
Steve uh you could with that GoPro to
bring back
I was going to bring down if you can
come out and just uh all right I've just
come so uh through lasback number one
and then yeah and then come back out and
give you a crew attack number two and
number three all right thanks and then
we'll be uh
you can get the the GoPro while I run
out to the
all right
let me get the
right
to both of the crew art bags
and then bring them down
and we copy
foreign
Grace
I want you to put this inside okay I'll
do that uh let me route your SCU first
okay
um
thank you
a visual of my uh
I do okay so I'm gonna hook through the
intelligent extender okay my
other way feather
and
all jokes get closed locked back and
left small hook
okay close what black and black
for yourself
can you reduce it from your side
ways all right to the handrail
oh okay hold on a second I got two
handful of the bag
of the SDS I can hand these bags here
all right
so I'll release that wave together I can
do that
yeah that'd be helpful and then I'll be
ready once you're done uh okay you're
away feather is really okay thanks
and I don't have your place to hook it
let's release it okay
be secured inside
okay
this view from Sultana nayari's helmet
camera
as he is inside the crew lock portion of
the quest airlock
and Steve can you confirm that's both uh
two and three
lock bags
too bad three right next to me
okay copy things
okay Steve ready all right here's two
oh hold on
all right let me try and roll over a
little bit more
because yours too
this view outside the airlock as NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen prepares to
Ingress
I'm gonna release yours okay
they're coming your way got it let's go
all right he wants to walk back through
uh
the International Space Station recently
crossed into an orbital daytime but in
the distance you can see Earth's Moon
destination of NASA's Artemis program
perfect
they have a red to it
I like May release my rescue back to you
I guess you're interested here okay you
can do that here comes that right coming
up to you all right all right give me
one second I'll go get the uh
GoPro and then I'll head out and we'll
see you again
so Curry locks one bags one two and
three are in the airlock so once we have
the GoPro in then uh Steve you can also
uh you can go out to the Anchor hooks
all right
the GoPro test
copy and we see you translating out
yeah I'm gonna Translate
this
I'll give you the big hook
and tell me when you get a secure it to
something
let me get to
all right
I'll give you the big Hook when you get
it okay
I'm gonna head out to the uh
all right I'll be waiting for you
good word that's good out to mile marker
5760.
60 on my way
is
it
foreign
[Applause]
and just for your awareness the arm is
going to move a little closer to esp2 no
impact
all right 57.50
triggered here
all right Steve as you get set your
first step is going to be to Rhett to
ev2's Anchor hook it's the one that's on
3217 the diagonal inboard handrail
32-17 rep to the Anchor hook
all right
we used to punch in the night a little
bit
foreign
camera of NASA astronaut Steve Bowen as
he continues cleanup procedures we are
now six hours and 34 minutes into
today's space walk
emirati astronaut Sultan on the Yadi has
ingressed to the crew lock portion of
the quest airlock
so see if you're going to rent to that
one as you are then you're going to
release it and hook it to your anchor
hook or sorry it that anchor hook to
your waist tether with gate closed
sliders locked
all right Jeff already
foreign
that's now your primary safety tether
path you are now go to release your
anchor Hook from 3011
just to your left and you can sew it on
your workstation
all right 30 11.
49 Steve all my videos are
all hooks are closed locked black on
black
attached to the airlock through my
Westerner both hooks are they close lost
black on black you're good to go all
right then head back you didn't go
there we got me Steve and good word
sultan
and Steve As you move inboard just a
reminder as you go by the cedar cart
we'd like you to depress those uh brake
pedals two times
all right
the fbu
and Sultan now that Steve's heading back
your way you are go to remove your SCU
from the stowage pouch and remove your
DCM cover and connect your SCU to your
DCM
foreign
having released the necessary anchor
hook as well as Sultan al-nayadi's
anchor hook
Steve Bowen is headed back to the
airlock following his safety tether
and Sultan you can also turn your head
off
The View below Bowen is that of the
North Pacific Ocean as the space station
travels 260 statute miles above it
is off
[Music]
breaks the Press
we copy big breaks depressed so you can
head back to the airlock and as you
enter the airlock you can also turn off
your hookup
all right
man if you could relay something to the
uh
73 we'd like to take our Queen to take
on foxtrot stick
we understand Queen to Fox 6.
and we'd like Costa to make that move if
you can before he gets annotated
he's on it
for
uh what's that supposed to do
a long wire side
so Steve that's to assist if the thermal
cover doesn't stay closed so we can
leave it where it is if you think it
might be in the way you can set it low
profile
take my licks
making my legs in and I'm gonna see if I
can reach there
okay see if you get to go I have all the
bags and the forwards I made up for you
cover
foreign
we'll have you Ingress and close the
thermal cover
and if you both want to this is where
you can reduce your tcv setting as you
get on the SCU it has warmer water so to
minimize risk of fogging you can reduce
your cooling just a little bit
okay
uh
prepare that get the cover in place
okay
see where you are
okay hey Steve
my legs are coming back then
let's try to get this on the magnetic
so Steve you're going to release the
hook from the stowage tether point and
attach the hook to the magnetic plate
d-ring and then cinch the strap until
snug six lines are visible and you're
going to verify the magnets engaged
foreign
[Music]
both back inside the crew lock portion
of the quest airlock now closing the
thermal cover ahead of closing the
airlock hatch
ES
very stripped up since
the magnet actually looks like it's
attached
I thought
right here let me adjust my Cooling
and Steve we can have you turn off your
heka and then you're going to be
removing the Su from its stowage pouch
removing your DCM cover and I'm gonna
see you
oh
my God
and a reminder now that you're in if you
wanted to reduce your TCB setting to a
lower number to minimize the risk of
hogging prior to putting on your SU
ccess
all right let me fix that
or ev2 got my
sdu connected to my DCM and my current
PCB settings is free
and copy your SEO is connected
all right I'm gonna try to make mine
colder
and I am at
seven
okay now I'm gonna get my sdu connected
uh we copy
[Applause]
thank you as well
I'll provide my FCU first of all okay
thank you I'm not sure what I'm bumping
up against
it's me sir I move forward
thank you
and try to find me after you pouch
okay maybe fine
is here
what does that mean
okay
all right if you here
give it to you now
okay
sportswear I just have three your hands
put your illustration
thought of your University workstations
you left on
yeah
we can all this stuff back clear again
ah
[Music]
foreign
if you could give us a line on how many
lines visible on this cinch strap for
the thermal cover
sure
I have
two three four five six
all right we like that answer so for
both of you you can now switch your
water to off ofs forward and expect
water is off message
hey everyone
order is off 82 what's the results
okay we copy Steve and Sultan you both
have your water offs and will hold here
for two minutes I want to take a moment
to congratulate you on the successful
spacewalk we're nearing 25 years of
space walks on the ISS in support of
assembly maintenance and upgrades
Steve congratulations on your eighth Eva
in your first in 12 years
Sultan you've now entered an exclusive
Club of humans who have stepped out into
the void of space and in doing so you've
marked a milestone for the United Arab
Emirates this is a historic moment for
the expanding face of global cooperation
congratulations to you both
okay and I don't think it didn't go
exactly if we had hoped but we were
trying something
that we had never really intended to do
and I thought that doesn't work but it
was a tremendous opportunity and I want
to really want to thank the
verbal Community for getting that
fast uh located where it was I would
have uh
headed to try and carry that with us but
everybody the whole team did a fantastic
job I really appreciate all the work
that goes put into it and it's been a
great honor to participants in uh
photon's very first spacewalk and I'm
sure he has a few words to say as well
thank you Stephen thank you um
um it's a great moment for um for the
UAE um
I would like to thank my leadership the
leadership of the UAE
and the USA specifically in brca
and NASA for believing in US and for
giving us this opportunity
this might be the first in the Arab
world I definitely won't be the last
We Have astronauts under training now to
undergo the commission to the ISS
the Luna service and to Mars so I would
like to thank everybody who helped
preparing us for this moment
I have
first of all allow me to say a few hours
quite a few words in Arabic
policy was
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you Steve and Sultan for those
words
ah
and that takes our two minutes so at
this time Steve you can verify the outer
hatch clear is is clear of hardware and
verify the handle position for the hatch
decal and then close and lock the hatch
all right
this is clear
we're supposed to see further detail
with both astronauts now back inside the
airlock Steve Bowen will close the door
close the airlock hatch
ahead of beginning repressurization
we're now at 6 hours and 54 minutes into
the spacewalk
again that spacewalk started when the
spacesuits were set to battery power
foreign
on the UIA you can check that oxygen emu
one and two valves are open
okay if you also your interview one and
two are open
you can switch the power ev1 and 2 to 1
on and verify the LEDs and volts
five copies one on everyone
and on BB2 and I have qmus LEDs around
copy and verify volts are 18 to 19.
that's affirmative easy one 18.6 evq
18.5
and I have
[Music]
um02 on eb2
okay we copy so both of you on your dcms
you can switch power to SCU and expect a
warning tone
[Music]
and that with that I will hand you back
over to Woody
thank you man thank you everybody
thank you and Steve Sultan welcome back
we're looking forward to getting you
inside on your DCM I'll have you take
your O2 actuators to press
press
as you do that verify that O2 act press
is displayed on your TCM
ground ivy and McLean has handed uh
duties back over to suit IV Woody hoberg
this view of the equipment lock portion
all right give me a minute
ah
a
usted
data
hold on
thank you
foreign
go to access
[Music]
over
[Applause]
and we've now crossed into the seven
hour mark of today's spacewalk that
beginning at 11 A.M Central Time
8 11 A.M central time this morning
closed all right we're going to start
the crew lock refresh now at 2012. let
me know if you'd like me to increase or
decrease the rate we'll start slow all
right thank you
repressurization of the crew lock
portion of the quest airlock has begun
four decimal zero PSI you can expect an
alert Zone
I love you
kick off
okay
how's the raid feeling
good here
and with repressurization of the crew
lock re uh beginning
that rounds out today's spacewalk time
at seven hours and one minute beginning
8 11 A.M Central Time and ending at 3 12
p.m Central Time
pressure in the
crew lock is now 1.27 PSI and climbing
during today's spacewalk the
astronauts uh
were able to Route some cables as well
as secure some multi-layer insulation
that prepares two mod kits for future
installation of the irosas these are
International Space Station roll out
solar arrays that we expect to arrive
later this summer
the crew then moved on to the rfg or the
radio frequency group that's part of the
s-band antenna the goal today was to
remove the rfg however they ran into a
difficult bolt which ended up breaking
off and were unable to remove that
portion of equipment
the team reinstalled the equipment and
so it is safe outside the International
Space Station
the astronauts then moved into cleanup
period before ingressing the airlock and
again we are in repress again that
rounds us out at a seven hour and one
minute space walk today
this was the eighth spacewalk for Steve
Bowen and the very first for sultan
al-niadi marking the very first
spacewalk for any emirati astronaut
s
ah
okay guys we're gonna hold here two
minutes for a leak jacket correction
three minutes for a league
with the completion of today's space
walk at seven hours and one minute we
have a readout of uh
our spacewalk stats so far in total this
was the 261st spacewalk in support of
space station assembly maintenance and
upgrades
it was a fourth out of the space station
this year but the second four Expedition
69.
today was the eighth spacewalk for Steve
Bowen totaling 54 hours and 19 minutes
and obviously the very first for alniadi
with seven hours and one minute
that was today's spacewalk total time
but in total with those 261 spacewalks
that is equal to 69 days 3 hours and 24
minutes of space walking time
guys while we're waiting here you can
check that your glove heaters are off
off
they are offered everyone
with you off
okay and check your gloves for
contamination let us know if you see
anything
let's have a couple uh little smears
by Grease or just
I don't know what
the usual black stuff normal
and maybe two gloves nominal
okay we copy a couple black smudges on
Steve's gloves and nominal gloves on EV
too
we got 30 more seconds so don't do it
yet but the next step will be O2
actuators to IV puppy
foreign
colors you can take your O2 actuator to
IV
all right Sophie
all right everyone
go to ID for ev12 E1 with a few ideas
well
copy that we're going to continue the
repress again let me know if you'd like
to change the rates
repressurization of the crew lock
continues
now at 5.1 pounds per square inch
they'll bring that up to about 14.7 PSI
which will equal out with the rest of
the International Space Station also
similar to what we are used to
experiencing on Earth
hahaha
[Applause]
I had just another headset near the end
of this repress you should expect one
more alert
[Applause]
laughs
elsewhere aboard the International Space
Station Sergey prokopia of Dimitri
petellen and Andre fed Yaya three horse
Cosmos cosmonauts are in the pre-sleep
portion of their evening
it's currently
8 23 PM GMT the time used aboard the
International Space Station
[Applause]
and the pressure in the crew lock is now
8 PSI
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
portion of the quest airlock where our
two spacewalkers
uh NASA Steve Bowen and uae's sultan
alnayadi await full repressurization we
are now at 11 PSI we'll bring that all
the way up to 14.7 to match the rest of
the International Space Station before
opening the hatches between the crew
lock and the equipment lock
Woody hoberg will then bring both
astronauts back into the equipment lock
portion and assist them in Doffing their
suits
oh
[Applause]
aside from some debriefs later this
weekend the crew will enjoy some time of
rest and relaxation
Saturday and Sunday ahead of getting
back into their scheduled work week on
Monday
ah oh
my God
[Music]
here in Mission Control Houston the
orbit 3 team is starting to arrive to
take over from orbit 2 they will conduct
a Handover in approximately an hour
oh
the orbit 3 team will remain on console
for the rest of the day
[Applause]
meanwhile aboard the International Space
Station repressurization continues now
at 13.7 PSI getting very close to the
14.7 we're looking for
laughs
all right guys we're gonna open up the
patch now
thank you thanks
[Music]
all right
ah
a
all right
foreign
[Music]
slightly
I'm wearing our Communications Handover
with the International Space Station but
it appears that the crew lock has
reached the appropriate pressure
we'll be standing by for hatch opening
shortly
again today's spacewalk started at 8 11
A.M Central Time and ended at 3 12 p.m
Central 7 hours and one minute
uh
foreign
and obviously those hatches have been
opened the crew has been moved into the
equipment lock portion of the quest
airlock
Woody hoberg at the bottom left of your
screen and Frank Rubio on the top right
are assisting Steve Bowen in removing
the safer the simplified aid for Eva
rescue
today was Bowen's eighth spacewalk and
he now has a total of 54 hours and 19
minutes outside the hatch
foreign
[Music]
ah
a
[Music]
what's up
as Coburg and Rubio
assist the crew in Doffing their suits
another recap of what was accomplished
today during the spacewalk
the crew started out by relocating two
articulating portable foot restraints
for future use
they then moved out to the S6 truss
where they worked on the 1B mod kit
they routed some cables for the
International Space Station rollout
solar arrays or eye roses that will be
installed later this summer after
arriving on SpaceX 28 resupply mission
to the International Space Station
they also secured some multi-layer
insulation around that mod kit
they then moved over to the 1A mod kit
and secured multi-layer insulation there
as well
both crew members then moved to the
radio frequency group work on the s-band
antenna the goal was to remove the rfg
bring it inside the International Space
Station and then send it back to Earth
for refurbishment however one bolt was
unable to be removed
and the station and the rfg was unable
to be removed from its substantion
therefore it was re-secured
the crew members then cleaned up their
work sites before ingressing again a
seven hour and one minute spacewalk
thank you okay
the helmet
Woody hoberg and Frank Rubio helping
remove the gloves from Sultan al-nayadi
and NASA astronaut Steve Bowen after
having completed today's seven hour and
one minute spacewalk
again the eighth spacewalk for Bowen and
a new history-making day for sultan
aniadi he's the first astronaut from the
United Arab Emirates to conduct a
spacewalk
two smiling faces after today's seven
hour and one minute Space Walk Sultan
anayadi of the United Arab Emirates on
the left and Steve Bowen of NASA on the
right
that will wrap up our coverage for today
you can check out nasa.gov live for all
of our upcoming events
but for now with the completion of our
spacewalk that'll wrap it up this is
Mission Control Houston
[Music]